jonas geht empire st marx und heute gibt
es eine runde ghetto wen hätte das
überrascht nicht wirklich leute ist es
schlimm
ich denke mir so kommt zocken eine runde
und dann mich so wie ich mich schon
wieder auf den rewe server begebe und
göttern spielen und irgendwie mag ich
das immer ich würde auch sagen ich bin
ein bisschen besser geworden
darin sei am anfang war ich ein bisschen
schlecht darin aber mittlerweile würde
ich sagen bin ich besser geworden und
ich sucht diesen modus was wirklich cup
heute ungefähr mannheim ins leben schon
gezeigt und deshalb dachte ich mir
bevor du wirst irgendwas aus der nase
ziehen software einfach dass wir die
ganze zeit lust oder obwohl die ganze
zeit bock drauf passen was du die ganze
zeit machst und ich hoffe mal sehr dass
es in ordnung ist für euch ich weiß
nicht weit in diesem modus auch so ab
bei mir das ist ganz krass aber ich habe
eine relativ gute idee was ich
vielleicht aufnehmen könnte
da wo ich dich mal euer feedback für und
zwar ist das was ganz untypisch ist
unser simon ein kumpel von mir schaden
an dich wenn du siehst hat zu mir gesagt
wie schaut's aus
kannst du oder willst du vielleicht mal
tower defense blums tower defense heißt
das spiel zocken und es ist wohl mega
lustiger sagt mir so ein bisschen was
gezeigt dass alte strategie zur als
17.000 upgrade möglichkeit so das klingt
jetzt voll nach placement weil ungefähr
jeder diese neun punkte fast eine erste
runde
das lincoln ablesen weil alle diese
tower defense sachen machen und so und
clash of cultures sonst aber es ist
nicht nicht mal irgendwas in die
richtung sondern ich überleg wirklich
das einfach zu machen davon gibt's auch
eine steam version
und ja das wäre glaube ich relativ
lustig dass man aus diesen schuh muss
daraus habe mir selbst dazu beigetragen
dass sich geschlagen wurde da vorne aber
ja das war meine strafe wahrscheinlich
dass jetzt gerade so dumm daneben
gesprungen bin
ich glaube an karma gleichen kader
eigentlich nicht ich weiß gar nicht was
für ein konstrukt dich glauben
vielleicht ganz wenig weiß okay halt
freude ich bin heute irgendwie voll
matschig und das ist voll crazy mann ich
bin immer so konzentriert so dass meine
augen wenn ich so ein paar runden jump
gespielt habe auch immer so voll wie
soll ich sagen so janovsky
das ist irgendwie von strange auf jeden
fall weil wenn man muss sich halt voll
konzentrieren
wegen diesen ganzen 1000 herum und wenn
man wenn sich das auch noch so schnell
weg das ist voll komisch für die augen
glaube ich und es wird ihn
wahrscheinlich auch nicht allzu gut aber
ich muss geld da und spielen
ich bin sicher
ich bin gibt auch richtig okay aber ich
glaube wir sind relativ gut 1000 punkte
für die zweite runde ist eigentlich echt
extrem stark stark sowie tony und ich
habe ja ab morgen ferien wie ihr
vielleicht wisst man jetzt mein abitur
in bayern
und leider werden das nicht fehlen wie
ich mir sie wünsche sondern es werden
schreibt eine verfickte seminararbeit
ferien für die wortwahl
ich bin kein gutes vorbild aber wirklich
ich muss jetzt echt eine seminararbeit
fertig machen damit diese woche ferien
jetzt und danach ist die abgabe ich
glaube dass es kein zufall dass das so
gelegen ist weil ich bin definitiv nicht
der einzige der das probieren wir
definitiv nicht der einzige der so spät
dran ist bzw
alle meine freunde sind ungefähr so spät
dran und einfach nicht geschafft 1359
auf jeden fall ist es meine letzte woche
jetzt wo ich das machen kann und das
wird ziemlich stressig also ich bin zwar
schon vorangekommen aber hat noch nie so
wirklich intensiv gearbeitet
es gibt halt einfach leute die haben da
so richtig spaß daran gehabt an der
arbeit war bei mir nicht so wirklich der
fall
acht konflikte wie viel verliere ich
jetzt bestimmt 170 schrecklich war bei
mir jetzt nicht so krass der fall also
ich hab hab mich das nicht jeden tag
freiwillig hingesetzt wenn ich die
finden war zwar mein thema voll cool
mein thema ist ja grenzübergänge
zwischen mensch und maschine am beispiel
ironman cooleren titel gibt es ja wohl
kaum noch mal nicht verliere ich aber so
punkte
durch meine dummheit hier aber irgendwie
kann es doch eigentlich
aber ich hatte ja in das ist halt immer
diese videos wo ich irgendwie fragen
antwort haben oder so ich irgendwie kein
bis so ein video hatte sich aber bei
diesem video vor allem bei gap down at
habe ich mich oft habe ich mich immer
dass ich 10.000 mal so oder so weil
diese konzentration ansprüche
nein ich möchte jetzt nicht mehr alles
bewusst ich es muss mich noch mal
konzentrieren
das ist schlimm aber ich konzentriere
mich halt schon so krass darauf dass ich
hier runter fallen ich runter falle dass
ich relativ wenig darauf achten kann wie
ich rede ich mag das überhaupt nicht an
mir nur dass ich dass ich so häufig er
sage ich sollte nicht darüber nachdenken
weil sonst habe ich mich nur dabei war
dies fast schon wieder gemacht
dieses video könnte ich das problem
nennt aber das tue ich nicht aber es
haben ja relativ viele glaube ich auch
wenn man sowas schul vorträge und so
angeht habe ich doch noch geholt
nach der zweiten runde raus gekommen ist
wenn man so schuh verträge hat kenne ich
auch 1000 leute die dicke probleme haben
damit damit solche sachen vorzutragen
kann voll verstehen weil ich mein bei
mir ist es nicht so ausgeprägt aber es
ist schon relativ merke ich finde ich
besser an breaking drei
sicherheitsstandards weit 22 es kommt
nie das raus was man möchte nie ich
hasse das feuer ist noch schaffen dann
ist mein leben perfekt
ok es gar nichts wert es gedacht ach
komm power anbrechen aber ich liebe
diesen enterhaken so sehr sehr schön
verkauf des ziehens was ich will mir
nicht sicher ich glaube das problem ist
weshalb auch immer wieder diese random
entscheiden uns rauskommt ist
dass das wahrscheinlich mit 17 und 18
spieler ist der server ich mich sicher
und das könnte dann wiederum probleme
verursachen so dass man halt diese
angezeigten enchantment auf seinen
sachen kriegt und misst das war unnötig
aber ich wollte doch schon irgendwas
kaufen mit dem ganzen zeug was jetzt
auch getan habe los geht's davon ist wie
anrainer und jetzt werden wir mal
schauen dass wir uns ein paar im gegners
näseln können ich würde euch nicht
darauf zu achten in meinen videos
ob ich das sage oder sonst werde ich
glaube ich sehr schnell den abonnieren
-button flaine bogen du das ist ich habe
noch nie ein flame bogen h auf level 30
von ihr ist es mit dem claim bogen als
ob nice den kann ich mir sowas von holen
den typen hab ich es gerade getötet oder
wenn ihr einfach aus dem framework kann
man sich über diese sehr runterziehen
ich glaube ich habe ihn getötet
perfekten ich krieg seinen flame bogen
alter das ist richtig jackpot ich glaube
ich habe sogar eine feier aspect schwer
für mich nicht alles täuscht power 3
alter das ist der krasseste bogen aller
zeiten ist noch mal ein paar extra
herzen weil wir es können
leute ich glaube das wird eine
erfolgreiche runde um runde geht wenn
man immer diese coolen effekte haben
möchte aber es ist ja echt erkrankte
bogen aller zeiten und er ist auch noch
so viele feinde gehabt
der dude hatte eine menge glück beim
entscheiden
verdammt ich will eigentlich sollte ich
jetzt auch ein bisschen mehr mit dem
bogen kämpfen wahrscheinlich wenn du
distanz möchtest größe die freundchen
die konstante haben das sage ich auch
immer so wenn ich sage ich habe auf pvp
konzentrieren du hast ja nicht mein
typen
das macht nur ich und das ist auch keine
gute idee
ich glaube zu gute komme dafür welcher
schon recht ähnlich in bedrängnis aber
hat er nicht weil ich das beste aller
zeiten habe so 3 kehrt schon vier
spieler noch mal schauen wie viele wir
uns von den holen können hochmut kommt
vor dem fall
so sind die leute das möchte ich mir
gerne abtrainieren dieses aber ich
glaube das ist so tief im menschen
verankert
da muss man glaube ich zur logopädie ist
die wissenschaftliche sprach so
sprachwissenschaft einfach wobei
wirtschaft von der sprache vom reden
vielleicht es tut mir wirklich leid was
ich euch hier zu sparen
nein es war nicht so gemeint ist nicht
schauen wir mal
aber ich fand die runde war geil
also auch dass wir uns diesen über
[ __ ] bogen geholt haben anregend 34 m
11 power 3 viel besser geht es gar nicht
wenn man nämlich eine höhere links hat
eine höhere punch
ein höheres punch enchantment dann finde
ich es das mega ätzend hier machen wir
diesen ihren vorjahr
als orchester und runter durch geschafft
so kommt nicht weil es ist nicht wie
diese funktioniert das nie ich denke
dann immer so okay jetzt drehe ich mich
so mega cool um aber der soll erst mal
sterben wenn ich das jetzt noch verliere
damit echten lofer peter dürfte mir sein
da wird wahrscheinlich viel machen
können gegen die power 3 bogen des
fleckens bitte holt der andere den ist
nicht ich werde in seinen keller
ziemlich an land der enterhaken
funktioniert irgendwie nicht immer so
wie ich es möchte holt euch nicht
gegenseitig möchte euch beide töten weil
ich möchte kates wo ich hatte als erstes
den nach möglichkeit karte häufig noch
möglichkeit
ich möchte nach möglichkeit weniger nach
möglichkeit zeigen wer ich bin mein geld
meint ja
es funktioniert nie wahrscheinlich darf
man sich dabei nicht drehen irgendein
trick muss es geben den ich nicht aber
ich habe noch fünf herzen also für extra
herzen und somit dürfte das machbar sein
diesen typen zu trumpfen kann ich nicht
souverän
doch kann ich okay ich bin wie lange
geht die runde schon 13 minuten
das recht eine ewigkeit so ich liebe das
einfach wenn man sich damit an anzieht
und er liebt es glaube ich auch jetzt
bin ich wieder außer reichweite für ein
enterhaken aber ich wollte ihm einfach
den bogen hit geben ich habe ja auch
genug weil um den mit dem bogen zu
erledigen
glaube ich eigentlich ins wasser zu ich
habe noch ein held gegeben ich hätte
sonst relativ leise ok perfekt das
verbrannte sie also das hat mich mein
budget und da will ich sagen würde ich
hoffe es hat euch gefallen tut mir leid
dass schon wieder getan weil aber es
macht aber zu viel spaß im moment was
geschieht